here are five things you probably need
to hear number one not everything that
happens to you is your fault but
everything that happens to you is your
responsibility right off the bat you
might think to yourself everything is my
responsibility how is everything that
happens to me my responsibility i can't
possibly account for every little thing
that life throws my way the chaos the
triumph and if something goes wrong
which it inevitably will am i supposed
to blame myself because i was
responsible for having that thing not go
wrong that's not really what i'm getting
at here because for most of us our
domain of influence is fairly small we
usually go to similar places we see
similar people we do similar activities
as we do most days and occasionally we
step outside the norm and we experience
new people places and things to freshen
things up and along the way we'll be put
in situations that we don't like
situations that make us feel
uncomfortable or angry we'll talk to
people that we think are idiots and
occasionally we'll be blindsided by
tragedy or misfortune i don't have to
tell you what life is like life is spicy
but if it is in our life it is our
responsibility to figure out what we're
going to do about it because who else's
responsibility is it who else is
responsible for your physical fitness
your mental health your social life who
else is responsible for the types of
people that you're inviting into your
life the type of reaction that you have
when something doesn't go your way when
you break it down like this it's really
hard to think of anything that's not
your responsibility anything that you
would realistically do interact with
experience aren't you tired of
delegating the responsibility of your
own flourishing onto other people it's
probably time that you have some
confidence and your ability to make
decisions for yourself to assume
responsibility over the outcomes of your
life regardless of whose fault it may be
because at the end of the day it affects
you so what are you gonna do about it
number two life gets easier when you're
on your own side if you love yourself
first and treat yourself with respect
you'll have more love to give when you
dislike yourself and treat yourself
poorly then you'll start to subliminally
feel unlikable and worthless and if this
is your default mode of being if you
continue to treat yourself poorly if you
don't like yourself very much then every
single interaction that you have with
every single person in your life will be
tainted with the need to solve this
inherent problem because we need to feel
loved and accepted and if you starve
yourself of your own approval off the
get-go then every interaction that we
have with people will be trying to gain
that approval back you'll start to rely
heavily on other people to make you feel
validated and worth something and if you
do this long enough you'll start to lean
on this external validation like a
crutch addicted to compliments
constantly searching for validation and
approval you'll start to wear clothes
that you don't necessarily like but you
think you're going to get a lot of
compliments on it you think you're being
kind of bold and brash by wearing it and
when you don't get that attention that
you so desperately require you'll start
to build resentment you'll start to feel
butt hurt you'll be kind of passive
aggressive for no reason because they
owe you something right every
interaction that you have
is an exchange you're nice to people you
compliment people just so that you can
be complimented back and if people treat
you poorly holy smokes that ruins your
day because when a person doesn't just
not return your compliment but they're
rude to you they become public enemy
number one because you've conditioned
yourself to place your entire sense of
self-worth in the hands of other people
but at the end of the day what you think
other people owe you you owe to yourself
if you start treating yourself like
somebody that you genuinely care about
and want the best for if you start
acting as if you're on your own side
then it will change every single aspect
of your life it will change the way you
walk into a room it will change the way
that you interact with other people it
will change the clothes that you wear
the way that you speak and every
decision that you make when you treat
yourself with respect and you love
yourself then you will actually be able
to give compliments without expecting
any in return you will actually have the
ability to be generous with your time
with your attention with your resources
because you genuinely want to it comes
from a place of abundance treating
yourself with respect just has a
ridiculous roi number three nobody owes
you anything you are not entitled to any
job position any lifestyle any
relationship just because you have big
muscles and workout doesn't mean you're
entitled to a hot girlfriend maybe your
personality is the equivalent of a wet
sock or a dirty diaper just because you
have a business degree from a community
college doesn't mean that you're
entitled to be on the board of directors
even if your business degree is from
harvard or some other prestigious school
you're still not entitled to anything
the type of person who walks around like
the world owes them something
usually comes from a place of lack
they're usually very ungrateful when
they get the thing that they think they
deserve and they're white hot and
vengeful when they don't get it the type
of person who thinks this way usually
has a giant ego they have an idea of
themselves that is disconnected from
reality in some way they probably have
some delusion of grandeur or they want
to appear on the surface that they're
better than they actually are but as
i've covered in previous videos
ego is brutal it distorts you from the
truth it stunts growth ego is far more
concerned with being somebody rather
than doing something and if you followed
step two and started treating yourself
like somebody you're responsible for
helping which is kind of a direct quote
from jordan peterson then you wouldn't
require others to give you things to
make you feel whole you will start to
want certain positions because of a
genuine confidence that you could add
value so instead of chasing status work
on developing competence focus on the
craft not the corner office because 99
times out of 100 your work will speak
for itself number four communism has
failed every time it was tried number
five it's going to be okay i don't know
what you're going through right now um
you could be having a very
great time in life it could be
you know probably the best time that
you've ever had you might feel energetic
and optimistic and like everywhere you
go there's a song singing behind you
a song singing behind you there's a
background track a cinematic score
elevating all of your steps butterflies
everywhere
but for a lot of people i know that's
indeed not the case i get the feeling
that there's a lot of people watching
the video that are in a very rough place
maybe they're going through something
that is just like incomprehensibly
tragic
you know
life has a habit of doing that
to a lot of people i know it's i know
it's hard to
think about it's hard to imagine that
things could be better for you and
sometimes it's not better for a little
while but life's kind of weird because
it seems like every dark period that
i've ever had in my life has always
turned into a period where
i looked back and i i never regretted
the dark period like there was always so
much to learn
in those periods of darkness so much to
learn about yourself
about other people
um and sometimes those realizations
about other people
are that you know people can be pretty
terrible
um but
i think that if you have compassion for
yourself if you have compassion for
others
if you realize that at the end of the
day you're still responsible for your
own happiness regardless of whose fault
uh your current happiness levels might
be you're still responsible for making
something of it and there is always
something to be made from it as long as
you're voluntarily willing to confront
whatever your situation is in with
humility and perseverance something good
always comes from it and that's been my
experience the only time something good
doesn't come from it is if you bury your
head in the sand and give up but even
then i feel like we're given
countless second chances in life so if
you are currently burying your head in
the sand
consider taking your head out of the
sand looking around dusting yourself off
and getting back on the grind because
uh at the end of the day
if you're willing to stick with it
things will be okay they always will be
okay even if you're not okay that's okay
too it's going to be okay
i just want to give a big thank you to
audible for sponsoring this video guys i
really want to recommend an audiobook
and that audiobook is make your bed by
william h mcraven the book was written
by a retired u.s navy admiral and it
really helps shift your mindset into
assuming responsibility over the
outcomes of your life so i really
recommend the read it's super short and
you could bang it out in one day very
easily as you're cleaning your house and
for those of you who don't know about
audible it is the leading provider of
spoken word entertainment and audiobooks
all in one place if you're even remotely
interested in self-improvement that's
just a wild guess that you are and you
want to enrich your life by enriching
the ideas that are bouncing around
inside your head then audible is
honestly a no-brainer as an audible
member every single month you receive
one credit which you can spend on any
audiobook of your choice regardless of
cost and you get to keep that audiobook
forever if you ever cancel your
subscription for any reason at any point
you still keep your entire library of
audiobooks audible members also get
access to a rapidly expanding catalog of
audible originals podcasts and exclusive
series so if you're interested in
joining me in becoming big brain and
filling your brain with the best ideas
on the face of the earth then if you use
my link in the description below you get
a 30-day free trial just click the link
head on over to audible.com better ideas
or you can even text better ideas to
500-500 so yeah take advantage of that
link or just text better ideas to
500-500 thanks again to audible for
sponsoring this video if you enjoyed
this video if you got something out of
it and you said this was a good video
thank you for that joey i appreciate you
i appreciate the work you're doing and i
just appreciate us i appreciate the
audience members and i appreciate living
life to its fullest then go ahead and
actually click the like button because
when you click the like button it
actually helps me out a ton because it
helps the video rank better it helps
push the video into other people's home
pages
helping them out helping me out it's
just a circle of love and life
and it's a win-win for everybody and if
you're lurking here consider subscribing
and helping my really sad instagram
instagram.com better ideas get more
followers because it's very sad like we
have 1.7 million strong here the youtube
community is just unreal
but our instagram
instagram's sad so if you're on
instagram anyways and you want to help
the better ideas
army
spread its wings like
i can't think of an analogy spread its
wings like
a
flying flying squirrel flying squirrels
do that i was gonna say a naked mole rat
but that would be
imagine like a naked mole rat that could
fly but yeah just help us
help us do that
do whatever you want i don't care